[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mélo et s'appelle corporation ttc
initial des menaces aux médias la somme
à rennes comme celle qui sévit
coin à moto à mort ozone et me mets pas
tes magnifiques au monde à être deux ou
trois jours marcia ausoni israël vous
utiliser la caméra c'est pour les
traumatismes des offres qui était
traumatisée par plusieurs violences la
capoeira est un art martial qui allie
mouvements de karaté pas de danse et
percussions
ce sont des esclaves africains vendus au
brésil qui l'ont d'invendus
[Musique]
d'après pour la défense de l'acaa les
bla arrivée dans la forêt ils y
trouvaient les esclaves déjà échappé
mais là il faut maintenant les combats
entre les esclaves et les bras
comme violette de quoi décourager il
faut pas désespérer et la patate amamou
mèche noire a passé stendhal et athènes
mais pourquoi risquer un mois et vit à
vancouver à cueto a redonné l'afrique
au début les jeunes sont sceptiques
puis petit à petit il emboîte le pas
barkat ndi existe mais ne va pas masqué
dans eyes wide open ma fille nous
attaquer ni tokai dans le terrain et a
fêté ses jumeaux nés kelkoo palais tout
est tout à coup l'un des six coups du
sort
pour du beurre je renseigne la capoeira
aux jeunes victimes de la guerre depuis
plusieurs années il se souvient très
bien des premiers jours de patrick qu'il
avait trouvé dans la rue quand il avait
commencé avec nous seulement il était un
enfant très compliqué l'avait problème
des troubles de comportement
alors qu'a eue avec les autres c'est
toujours fait la guerre battre les
autres gibiers les autres la traque est
devenu chef de famille à huit ans
responsable de ses deux petits frères
alors qu'il n'ya pas tomber avant la
maman ou alors c'est pas les abandonner
d'abord par son père puis par sa mère
quelques années plus tard au moment où
il fut qu'un toit - à quelques shing
mais après tout acheter draka est sa
adelinda aux douanes chinoises wang jing
twitter qui bataillent ont passé les
votes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
après avoir vécu dans la rue quelques
temps une tank retrouve les trois frères
et les hébergent
mais patrick continue d'arpenter les
rues pour trouver à manger une vie dure
il donne et reçoit beaucoup de coups
capoeira l'aide exorciser cette
agressivité
nous sommes approchés à gossi à quoi bon
coup et vous partirez nestoria capot
[Musique]
basé sur l'histoire
d'ici là les valettois comme les
esclaves et comité capot et là c'est
vrai qu'à cela ne tienne la manu moser
est ce qu'elle ne fera escale à savon
bio
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quelqu'un qui est stressé bien un
problème quelqu'un qui est traumatisée
cathy voile commence à chanter ça aide
ah ah ah sue à faire quitter les
problèmes qui est dansokho dada dans sa
tête au bédat soccer et quand la tête et
le coeur sont moins longs on peut plus
facilement apprendre à lire à écrire à
envisager un avenir meilleur mais
l'animatrice l'amnesia quoi passe
colonies j'aimerais être psychologue dit
patrick pour aider les autres surtout
les enfants traumatisés
car je peux comprendre ce qu'ils ont sur
le coeur
[Musique]